guys welcome to the audacity Network and
welcome to another episode of the sit
down today I have a special guest on the
channel he has a YouTube channel with
1.2 million subscribers arguing the case
for and educating people about Islam
welcome to the show Muhammad hijab thank
for having me thank you for coming so I
think when I first
um when I first decided to have you on
the show you messaged me something about
a lot of My Views are similar to Islam
so I was curious what what
views well of course I mean look U if
I'm being open and transparent with you
um what's happened let's take this
historically because what's happened in
the west is that there was the feminist
movement and you had two major waves the
first wave and the second wave first
wave of feminism maybe you could say
after the 1920s and it focused on the
vote and stuff right that's probably a
point of difference I I don't have an
issue with the vote I know that you've
been uh tweeting about the woman's vote
to be honest I see I think it's the root
of all evil no I I think you haven't
argued that point well enough to be
honest we can we can talk about that but
the second wave feministic output okay
this is where a lot of the issues of
society that we would agree as Muslims
traditionalist Muslims would be because
it's not just about equal pay and all
that kind of thing we I don't have an
issue with equal pay it's about domestic
drudgery it's about the new attitude
that the West is now having uh Vis the
mother Visa the family unit Visa um what
is success what constitutes success for
a woman in general and that was what
could be conceived to be diametrically
opposed to Traditional Values in Islam
Judaism Christianity and
cross-culturally historically for a very
long time so the fact that there's been
a response to it some academics have
labeled this as the backlash literature
okay so that you've had from the' 60s to
like 2000 you've had all this feminist
output and now people are coming out and
responding to it and one of the first
books that I came across um was a book
called The Myth of male power I'm not
sure if you've come across a very
important one by worldl faren and he
kind of set the trend a little bit I
think academically then you had a range
of different outputs and I would
compartmentalize the outputs into two
different types you had what you would
call academic output so people like
James Tully has a very interesting book
called The miseducation of women yeah
very good book it's part of the backlash
literature for instance right um we've
already mentioned world faren but then
on the other hand you had the cultural
leaders people that were making sound
you know noise on the internet and stuff
like that and I think um probably the
most effective person was Andrew Tate
mhm okay I think we would all agree if
if there was one person that phenomenal
yeah one person has had like a media
rise like that yeah overnight basically
absolutely so you you have people like
Andrew Tate and I would say Kevin
Samuels as well from a cultural
perspective and I would put sneo and
yourself and other people in that same
bracket um now this is usually referred
to as the red pill movement or something
like that obviously from an academic
perspective there's not much that has
been produced from a red pill
perspective only Rollo
has really I would say put in effort in
that regard notable effort he's written
his book um the rational male I'm not
sure if you've come across it or you've
spoken to him about it yeah but that
seems to be an organized set of ideas of
some sorts apart from that the red pill
movement has been I would say the
most um
loud um kind of
cultural uh produ producer of of
knowledge if you like and attitudes uh
which has been a response to feminism
since the 60s mhm that's what I think
that's the history of it and so I think
everyone deserves their recognition as
part of that movement but I also think
that the redpol movement has gone into
overcorrect mode and you know sometimes
when the pendulum swings too much in One
Direction it swings an equal an opposite
amount in the other direction and I do
think that there are some things in the
red pole movement which I've already
voiced you know with many different
podcast uh recently fresh and fit mhm uh
which I think are also not not right or
incorrect or incoherent or whatever
however a lot of the stuff needed to be
said I must say and so where I think
what you've said agrees with Islam or
agrees with the position which I would
say is more favorable to women anyway
from a psychospiritual
perspective is obviously the focus on
traditional roles obedience to the
husband which is a very I mean to say
obedience to the husband in the 60s and
70s when the feminist movement was fresh
would be Blasphemous sacrilegious and
for for someone okay to come out and
speak about that as in yourself and
other people is definitely seen as uh as
a very audacious no pun intended
obviously this place called audacity
right yeah very audacious thing to do
and very in our in our sense very
praiseworthy you know in our religion
for example in Islam and I would say in
Judaism as well and I would say
traditional forms of Christianity in all
three abrahamic quotequote religions
this has always been a thing you know uh
this has always been a thing and
cross-culturally and once again
historically this has always been a
thing and there's good evidence that
suggest that this this kind of family
unit this kind of structure is what
brings people happiness contentment it
makes a Better Living for children for
families it's good evidence I'll give
you one piece of evidence the longest
study that has ever been produced
us uh on the well-being of women in the
west is a study called blanch flower and
Oswalt okay which took place between the
1970s until
2000 and you'll note that this study
took place after the 6s after many of
the laws had now been passed in America
and in the UK and other
places which gave women the right to
work and you know equal pay and all
these kind of things abortion all that
kind of stuff all right but then what we
find
is a we find that women are now finding
it harder according to the study they
have become more
dissatisfied um so obviously we can't
say correlation equals causation but
what we're saying is there's good
evidence that suggest even to the extent
to which even the founding mothers of
feminism like betti fedan and others
they acknowledged that this the feminist
movement now took
a a shape of its own and it was having
an impact on women's health you know she
said it herself uh Betty fedan who wrote
obviously the Feminine Mystique in 1963
in the 70s and
80s she came and said that this movement
now has become religious feminist
movement and what she had said about
it's become religious yes it's become
something which even she tried to to
stop it from being like that the
feminist feminism had become like pseudo
religious okay you see what I mean I
thought you meant like what I was like
what religious no I mean when I say
religious satanic when I say religious I
mean like it's it's taking on the traits
of someone who believes in feminism
right exhibits the same physiological
and psychological traits as someone who
follows a religion would exhibit MH so
she she acknowledged that and she
realized she actually conducted her own
study okay um in her second book that
she wrote the second sage and she said
that Women's Health has become worse so
there's no evidence that feminist
prescriptions have been good for
society and where we agree
wholeheartedly and definitely is on the
point that okay we need to go back to a
more traditional right way of living and
that's better for everyone
MH obviously where we disagree is that
look I mean some things like I would say
the stuff that you just mentioned like
you know the woman's voting and stuff
mother of all you I don't know if the
argument has been made strongly enough
if I'm being honest with you like I
don't know if you've made the argument
for well I I actually do say that some
women can vote Yes if they're not on
child support alimony they're net
taxpayers they're in the military or
have an infrastructure job my point is
if we made those the requirements maybe
land owners business owners but if we
made that the requirement most women
wouldn't vote
anyway look look you know historically
we're g to go to technicality you know
historically um
okay there's a difference between
representative democracy and direct
democracy right democracy came out from
Athens you know thousands of years ago
maybe 2,500 2,400 years ago and um
actually in the first instance at least
in Athens not in Sparta and other places
but there women were excluded from the
vote I mean Plato has a whole criticism
of voting for The commoners but and he
says that the people who should vote are
those who are like the elites the
intellectual Elites because why should
we have done people voting anyway in
society that's his position I would say
that position is much more respectable
than yours though but only because it's
like what you've said can be applicable
to certain uh groupings of men do you
know what I mean what do you if you
think about it right there are some
people let's say for example we can do
this in a myriad ways if you've got a if
you've got a woman who's a PhD right M
and she's she's a specialist in a
specific area then you've got a man who
I find that phds these days it doesn't
me let's say let's go to the um
conventional race realist favorite uh
go-to thing IQ okay fine okay I let's
say A man does IQ test and he gets 50
and a woman gets 15 okay see I'm I'm
Different I don't really believe in IQ
me and you both I mean I have my own
criticism of the IQ test okay but yeah
I'm fine I understand but what I'm
trying to say is that like you know it's
if if if it's based on
uh
Prudence then we have to now if you say
okay well there's certain segments of
society that shouldn't vote over a
certain age and that's based on Prudence
then let's put the you know the
parameters there and you're going to dis
you're going to not include a lot of men
in there as well yeah well I I don't
think men that don't pay taxes don't you
know I I don't think men that like are
on benefits should really vote either I
I just don't think it's fair that like
like I think the problem we keep getting
into is that are living off the system
keep voting for more and more handouts
and and that's kind of the issue that I
have with it and women are just the
majority of people on
benefits so well women are majority of
people on benefits so now this is not an
argument about who's best at choosing
the right politics it's about not
including people who take from the
system or they're using their vote yeah
yeah true but I'm saying it's mostly
women that take from the system sure but
then if we say the same thing we could
one can respond to that quite easily and
say well look at the bankers in this
country for example right they get away
with the most they've got the most money
coming in but they get away with the
most they don't have to pay anything in
terms of taxes and stuff like that they
they threatened and leverage the
government and so on so um I don't know
enough about so for example like in 2008
there was a recession which was a
worldwide recession but obviously was
felt particularly heavily here in the UK
and London and so on and you know the
government had to bail out the bankers
you know and this led to a lot of const
resentment in the mass population oh so
is that like like we had that 2007 2008
oh okay same thing happened here same
thing but the idea is that it's not it's
not a correct thing to think that it's
only the let's say workingclass
socioeconomic grouping that gets to
leverage the government say or use the
government or use the vote to enact
policies which are in its best interest
aside from the interest of say the
majority of people because the bankers
and the elites also do the right well I
guess um cuz I I think you're are you
saying that I'm saying the middle class
wouldn't vote then is that what you're
no I'm just saying that depending on
like what parameter we use yeah so for
example if we say let's use an IQ
parameter let's use an intelligence
parameter right it's not going to be a
whatever parameter we use it doesn't
seem like it's going to be a gender
issue then well I I think whatever
parameter we use women would still
mostly not vote cuz I would include
infrastructure like I think the pl
should be able to vote the elect like
people actually running the backbone of
society I just think there has to be
some skin in the game yeah the thing is
when we say skin in the game is this
would be a bit of a tension between what
you say here and then what you say what
woman should do
because correct me if I'm wrong but your
idea of women should be at home right as
Homemakers sort of but yeah mostly if
you have children yes sure okay so they
don't have any skin in the game in that
sense because they're not paying taxes
if they're at home
so you can't send these women signals
you know yeah then then you get your
husband voting you're supposed to listen
to him anyway right no I get what you're
I understand what you're saying but do
you see like whatever parameter you use
you're going to see an issue with it
that's why you have to rethink these
arguments a little bit maybe you just
but even the Homemaker it's not like
most women are Homemakers anyway in this
Society so something you want to change
I mean there well I I I think it would
be better but I wouldn't predict it I
guess I'm kind of a I'm like a happy
pessimist okay I just I don't think
that's going to happen in my lifetime if
I had to guess yeah so that's one issue
that we disagree and it's not
necessarily um I I Just Disagree because
I don't think the force of the argument
is there I think you need to think about
the argument a bit stronger that's
that's all and just because so that's
one thing I mean but the other thing I
think is an approach though MH because
you know I've gone through your channel
not all of the videos but mostly the
shorts um I think your shorts have done
very well part of your success has been
your shorts has it and um there was a
theme there I mean look once again
everyone can do their own thing I'm not
but the theme was okay women need to
take accountability and I agree with
that theme MH do you know what I mean
like okay a women need to take
accountability but I also think men
should take accountability okay so how
do we do this because if you tell people
that okay you need to take
accountability for example women right
modern women are the least accountable
of any generation mhm but so so are mod
men like compare the modern man with the
medieval man he fails in almost every
metric mhm um men are now junkies they
are you know Desperados they are you
know losers they a lot a lot of men in
the west and elsewhere not just the in
the Muslim world as well compare them
with their medieval equivalent in terms
of warrior status and what they've done
on the battlefield in terms of what they
do in terms of protecting their family
MH so I do think that because here's the
thing I think with relationships um you
get we have a trend now of people both
men and women trying to deflect blame MH
so a lot of men yes they the red pill
stuff it resonates with them and for
good reason because people in the red
pill are saying things that need to be
said and I'm the first one to admit
this um that women need to take
accountability that women to obey their
husband all that kind of stuff
traditional roles all that kind of thing
I agree with that you know I'm a Muslim
at the end of the day we're conservative
we're very conservative we're we're more
conservative than any conservative in
the west like you know if we really
think about it we're so conservative
that it wouldn't even be called
conservatism
um be far right yeah no no not far right
because that the whole Spectrum the
political Spectrum from what perspective
is different oh my gosh it's way more in
depth than I thought like when I first
got into it I was like I'm conservative
but there's like so many different
layers that I didn't even know before I
got into itly because the issue is with
conservatism is that it depends on like
in America they have Neo neoconservatism
in England you have traditional
conservatism that was like prated by
someone like Edmond buck and all of it
is not what we are but we have aspects
of cons conservative ideology which we
agree but the point I was making was
this is that um I do think that like the
message is partly right MH and as I say
we agree with it but there needs to be a
bit more pushing accountability for men
as well and there needs to be a bit more
consiliary approach what's conciliatory
like harmonizing you know we we need we
want to harmonize between because the
thing is at the end of the day men and
women can't live without each other and
we need to get along with each other mhm
I've I've met many women who are emited
and I've met many men who are emited
like they've either had a bad breakup or
someone's taken money from them or their
ex-wife has taken off their wealth all
of this stuff I disagree
with however and that needs to be called
out mhm but I I do feel like that
there's a there's a time now is we need
to try to get men and women together to
work as partners rather than as
competitive